while there's been a shooting in Moscow
near the headquarters of Russia's main
Security Service the FSB leaving at
least three people dead now that's taken
place just in the last couple of hours
you're watching live pictures now from
the streets of Moscow near where that
happened where the streets have been
cordoned off our correspondent step
Vasan is there for us in Moscow step I
know this happened very recently but
what do we know at this stage we're
hearing that at least one of them was an
officer yes the latest Sur reports were
now see these are media quoting the FSB
a press service they say that inside the
headquarters at Lubyanka the main
building the attack started three
attackers came in and the two has been
that killed during the shootout with
allegedly other empathy officers one of
them managed to escape and ran into the
street where he also managed to kill a
traffic police personnel and then later
the embassy I would be has also made
public that they killed they said
neutralized they killed this last
attacker as well that's the latest
information that we have so far but it
still very sketchy and how did could
happen how these people would answer
this very and secured building in the
heart of Moscow
the atmosphere is of course the old KGB
the Secret Service and the Soviet Union
time was one of the most acute buildings
in the country and in the city so
there's still a lot of questions
President Putin was actually attending a
concert to memory to commemorate the at
Morrie's day of the FSB at the same time
the shooting I was taking place
the spokesman officer President Putin
has said that he has been briefed on the
situation but it hasn't been any comment
so far from any government officials
except that we also saw that the Health
Ministry has said that they have been
super seriously injured as the people as
well I'm seeing now reports that a
source close to the FSB says that the
shooting incident could be linked to
Putin's speech today do we have any idea
about the motivations that might have
been behind the
this attack and I imagine the security
services are taking the investigation
incredibly incredibly seriously well
it's not very clear what the motivation
has been and there's no speaker so far
about this but yes it was today's annual
press conference by President Clark
actually a support on for hours and he
was asked during that press conference
was the most serving event was during
this 20 year long pool and he mentioned
terrorist attacks and he said that the
especially the one in 2004 at the school
it's like we might have 300 people were
killed mostly children was the most
disturbing one and he also mentioned
that Russia with much more trouble these
terrorist events many of them have been
prevented and also something that the
police keeps telling everyone the attack
was in 2017 are the 50 natural then it's
been calm again we don't know of course
at this stage if this was a terrorist
attack on what the motives are behind it
that police's ever be saying that
they're still trying to identify the
person that they have been shot indeed
step fasten they're on the line for us
from Moscow we'll be bringing you more
on that as we get it thank you step